[Music]
foreign
lasts until morning look at him uh
you're gonna help us get where we need
to go
there we go
[Music]
I don't need your help
I've been trusting your broken ass all
through these Hills what the hell you
doing boy get out Billy D they all dead
because of you
so he's a slave thing you see chains on
me
or mess around here marking orders
ain't been no slaves since I ran out
that Plantation
towards my world
just as I'm on me it's a fusion of
negross I've seen you twice in one day
they know about the real room who slave
run and it's me
I'm not a warrior like you kids yeah you
damn right you not your coward we're
gonna hurt you there like dull
hear me
jokes
no rules in war
you got to find yourself boy
find yourself
we get calls too
got a reason to win ain't no hiding the
truth will the truth is just waiting to
be found in God damn it we found it was
it
guards in this fight now